what's going on john watch your arm rest
i'm sorry
what's going on people we're gonna watch
the next episode of one division today
episode five if you haven't done so
already subscribe and click that
notification bell to get notified when
our next
one division reaction is up while you're
at it go ahead and hit that like button
if you end up enjoying our video too as
per use i do got to mention that this is
qualifies as reaction highlights
full-length threats and watch alongs
where you sync it with the time code
will be available over at our patreon
page
and enormous thanks to everyone who has
gone and shown their support over her
patreon thus
far over there at the same tier you get
the option for reaction highlights and
watch alongs for shows like supernatural
doctor who attack on titan avatar the
last airbender
psych just a whole bunch of shows look
at all the thumbnails trying to read all
the titles
there's a whole lot over there and also
of course gotta thank our buddy eric
over at nerd chronic for editing these
reaction highlights for us to put up
here on the channel guy gets up
super early in the morning or stays up
super late at night it's somewhere at a
time where people shouldn't be awake and
he's chopping away to make sure this can
get visible on youtube so thank you so
much for all your hard diligent work
give them a follow today anywho guys
let's do this
[Music]
i know parents aren't supposed to take
shortcuts but i think this situation
calls for one
don't you careful don't do it careful
there wanda
[Music]
why won't you do what i want what does
that do why won't you do what i
want she can't control the babies
that's their stair mephisto
[Laughter]
or maybe we just need some help
she looks like kelly kapowski agnes
you're a
light saber be careful of their belly
button
and i'm also examining the background do
you want me to take that again
what i'm sorry
you want me to hold the babies
she crying what the hell's happening oh
this is so strange
this is compellingly awkward
what was that about what was what
i wish you looked at you how did she
look at me well i didn't
oh lavender ralph's crazy on me every
night but there's no taming this
freaking ralph where is he do you hear
that
hear what absolutely nothing
they're empty then where are the twins
mommy
daddy
[Music]
can't control them no matter how hard
you try
that's twice they brought up controlling
[Laughter]
yes
wow she really really looks like like
mary kate ashley in those younger photos
that is that's delightful
these are good songs it really paid off
getting them to score this i'm monica i
know i'm
a big fan we're gonna need to take these
again
born in sokovia in 1989 to irina
and oleg maximov subsequently
radicalized volunteering at hydro
oversimplification of events but
yes after unspecified experiments
he's so good at this dry deliver does
maximuff have an alias
no sir no funny nickname like scarlett
witch
lagos and germany we all know how that
turned out oh come on man
we knew you were a dick we knew it just
confirms it
i uh try not to speak
this morning i received authorization to
share this highly sensitive material
from sword headquarters
it was the top secret location damn
so they did have his corpse
holy moly
oh then she took it from the nine days
ago
maximoff stormed our facility stole the
whole body
resurrected and this is the first time
you're mentioning this
maximoff in her grief disregarded his
wishes
all right that's it for now oh no you
got something to do with this
yeah yeah bringing this up right now
no no man what happens when he learns
the truth
i think we're about to fight f stated
for the episode
bless you thank you these kids are
kind of like horrible this episode is
straddling like
endearing and creepy all at the same
time
can we keep him who's outside
crying
you telling me oh so spark your dog
daddy
10 10. 10 years old
next episode or 10 minutes from now
right now right now
what i miss the twins aged up to 10.
darcy got her coffee she got the coffee
what's the heck oh um that's what i'm
calling the anomaly because of its
hexagonal shape it's starting to catch
on
wanda's twins are hers everything might
look fake in the tv but
everything in there is real she should
know she delivered
yeah no they're real all right
yeah there you go
classic
whoa whoa what did not create any holes
or no
wow wow those
pants are 87 kevlar
what illusion wanda is
rewriting reality cool what happens if
we send something in that requires no
change
oh go in already 80s doubt
sword top secret communique oh no okay
what doctor don't see lewis
[Music]
please please help me taking care of her
dad he's sick
where's my phone you have to stop her
stop oh oh my god
in my head
now tell me this oh snap
oh damn speed
nice sparky vision must have done that
before based on the notes
right probably yeah but he's always
going to be your brother
and he's always going to be yours do you
have a brother mom
he's far away from here and that
makes me sad
i know this is tech from the 80s but can
we sharpen the visuals
max them off located well done we can't
see the drone on the bride
i hate you i just want to talk
that's it
take the shot what did you do
i'm a cliche of an [ __ ]
he's going to kill the drone he's going
to shoot the drone before
i wouldn't be surprised
[Music]
oh
hayward if you were such a dick i'd be
on your side
oh damn take your [ __ ] and leave me
alone
this will be your only warning
shooter accent you don't bother me
i won't bother you oh damn
you're still here
oh no no no you trusted me to help
deliver your babies on some level wanda
you know
i am an ally and no one
will ever take it from me again
snap
i love how monica turned to her she just
knew wanda wouldn't actually make them
pull the trigger
wow you've got a mess you need lagos
brand paper towel
the most absorbent paper towel available
for when you make a mess
you didn't mean to
sound sparky
what i didn't want to come until i had
wrapped him up
oh no i didn't find him until it was too
late
what she's killed the dog i don't
believe you
you can fix anything mom fix it dead
what i am trying to tell you
that there are roles in life we can't
reverse death no matter how sad it makes
us
some things are forever oh
damn coming back mom
bring hope back
elizabeth olsen's so good i know come
here
so she pretty much just confirmed
vision's still dead right
yeah that's certainly the vibe i have
beginning
they had his body he broke in for it
and some things that are dead stay dead
i unearthed the man's suppressed
personality and i spoke to him free of
your obesity oh
[ __ ] wow you can't control me the way
you do them
can't i oh no
[Applause]
you do not credits me i don't know what
you're talking about stop lying
oh no oh no you've never talked to me
like this before
before what i can't remember my life
before
oh i don't know who i am damn
your tommy and billy's father isn't that
enough
i don't know how any of this started in
the first place
my mind is so [ __ ] up
oh
what's up magnus start with hurt
[Music]
waiting to be surprised the cat's the
cameo who is this
is it pim is it
is it is it is it hank pym is it
ian mcallen
[Music]
oh
it's already starting long lost bro get
to squeeze his stinking sister to death
or what
oh weird she recast
pieces
[Music]
they recast me oh my god is this
happening
oh my god
no whoa that was crazy
the hair was like i know sorry what's
going on
from the front that that was a roller
coaster i feel like you know that last
time
dude it's quick silver's that's the
x-men quick that
that right there x-men coming no somehow
they're going to be doing this
i oh man the theories are going to blow
up this weekend
will we get a home sequence before the
end of the season
oh you guys have to jack all right so we
just watched that scene back definitely
not just a recast because that is the
personality of the quicksilver
from not just evan peters
that is the quicksilver evan peters like
the the sense of humor the lines they
gave him
the yeah the big bro you know like
that's
that is not the eric taylor johnson
virgin at all that is the
x-men universe version of it living with
this
we're doing it oh [ __ ] damn
the authentic sakovian version it's
really happening
oh man we always knew it was coming but
it's like would it be recasting
damn that is crazy yeah what an
interesting reveal because
it seems apparent that vision is still
dead like that was a
something that a lot of us already
concluded based off of zombie vision
from last week's episode
but you know there was still that
question of maybe
maybe but that conversation she's having
with tommy and billy who by the way i
love how they're colors of their clothes
represent their outfits of wicking and
speeding yeah that conversation that
she's having with tommy and billy
after sparky dies the way she's talking
about
resurrecting and then when people are
dead and then especially right when
vision shows back
up vision being like i don't remember
anything of who i
am before any of this what's outside of
west view she really doesn't want him to
go outside of west view that's pretty
much a confirmation
vision isn't indeed dead still that was
what was the interesting part to me was
that she wasn't able to bring vision
back from the dead
yet somehow she brings
pietro back see i think it's it's a case
of she doesn't
realize she either has some sort of
amnesia or doesn't realize the full
extent of her power and maybe what she's
grieving over especially
strong or something is the key to that
like i you know obviously we don't know
but it seems very clear that she
is conflicted in that moment talking to
them and yeah vision i mean they keep
even him calling him popsicle at the end
all hinting to the fact that she's
reanimated him and probably either
doesn't know or is in heavy denial over
it i think
what if that is exactly the x-men
quicksilver one from the fox
universe from before then it's not a
resurrection right
yeah that that is not a resurrection of
quicksilver
some kind of inter-dimension yeah
something when they said aerospace
engineer when monica rambo was
saying like i know someone aerospace
engineer and she was gonna make a call
or something
my mind was thinking hank pym maybe so
that's why i thought that was hank pym
when he
uh at the door it could be rhodey
actually um
because rhodey was part of the air force
rambo with the air force and all that
aerospace engineer background and also
uh don chino did recently just talk
about how he's gonna be a falcon winter
soldier soldier too
so perhaps it'll be rhody who shows up
in this series either way
that's why i was thinking hank pym
initially but dan that raises so many
questions that i can't wait for
people smarter than us to figure out
what that means
before the show tells us to regularly
bring in tons of x-men and it'll just be
yeah beast next well it's it still
raises a lot of questions because
a the house episode was hinting that
this hayward guy was a douche
and in this episode we're like those
little hints you were getting that he's
a dick
let's really the guy you hated the head
of all these organizations and all these
movies making the stupid cliche
decisions
there's just something really off about
like when he shows the footage
of one breaking in taking vision's
body where they have vision's body being
held i was saying
just the way he was presenting the
information you're like you see you
don't feel like you kind of wanted this
to happen you seem like you're playing a
part right now
because even wanda when she's talking
with vision at the end when the walls of
this reality are coming down she's
starting to be a little bit more real
with vision
before quicksilver shows up she's even
saying
i don't know how any of this happened do
you think i'm really controlling all
this
i feel like there's something about that
guy that wanted this to happen
in some way they're talking about like
sentient programming a.i
all that in the last episode i feel like
he
wanted wanda to kind of do this with
vision specifically
i don't know there's so much there's so
many questions here and then like even
agnes that scene at the beginning
oh that was so surreal and straight like
because she really does just kind of
completely
naturally flow out of the flow of the
scene and it caught me up because
at first i was like did i miss something
did she like drop some line of dialogue
yeah i think it was just the oddness of
yeah vision
having his little freak out moment like
i don't want you to hold them and then
her like really zeroing in on that
fact was really like a great example of
how this episode
blended it's really unsettling balance
of tones together because i don't know
what to make of that some people were
thinking it might
fall in line with the comics a bit more
of like uh produce wicking and speed and
agnes is really agatha harkness and she
seemed
really really hesitant
to even hold wiccan and speed or tommy
billy she even seemed
really hesitant to hold them right that
was the thing that threw her out of the
scene like you
you want to do that again you want me to
like like she seems
scared yeah which seemed off because you
know that scene with norm i know we're
kind of hopping around here a lot but
you know that scene with norm when
vision breaks
uh the subconscious barrier or whatever
it's her
stop her he doesn't specifically say
wanda
i was like maybe it's agnes but then
agnes was kind of scared
and then agnes at one point was maybe
agnes seek is a secret agent for hayward
i could say
imagine somebody on the outside having
an influence or having an
interest in what's going on in here and
yeah agatha has to
agnes has to be allied with someone
dubious just because she is the one
unaccounted for identity in this world
and so i mean if she is agatha harkness
which seems kind of likely you know she
would be the one who can at least
navigate
the nature of this even if she's not you
know fully confident because of wanda's
tremendous power
because agnes is always there at the
drop of the hat to help out she doesn't
seem weirded out by wanda's powers
only the time the only time is when one
of the boys
i forget which one says bring back
sparky from the dead and then she's like
you can
do that but wanda is also getting
comfortable
showing her powers in front of her yeah
agnes
doesn't seem to question what's going on
personally maybe norm is talking about
maybe agnes is actually don't call this
but me i'm starting to wonder maybe
agnes is actually someone working for
hayward directly
to monitor the situation to keep aiding
and want that's what seems really off
about that
the presentation of the footage of juana
taking the body
allowing that to happen even jimmy wu
was like questioning that
yeah like wait a minute yeah he brings
up the whole sokovia accord
and by the way the lagos uh commercial i
thought was brilliant messes you didn't
mean to create or something like that
that incident in ligo and lagos was the
the linchpin
having the sokovia cords she was just
trying to do the right thing
causes a mess and now she's trying to
like clean up her messes
yeah i love that i love that it's a it's
a really cool like
visual comments because the commercials
really seem to hone in on her traumas
well yeah and that commercial even as as
like fun of a gag as that is was like
also jarring that's the thing is this
thing had a tone throughout that was
like amusing
fun but always off just enough to keep
you really unsettled or keep me really
unsettled that's what i got to commend
the show for in the filmmaking aspect
like two things i really want to point
out one you know did i see this
cons there's still a thing that people
are arguing about why is one division
weekly why spawn division weekly still
why didn't they release it all at once
it's like you talk about the business
things and all that
i think too because of the fact that
this is based in this world of wandas
creating
sitcoms that aired weekly i feel like it
works
in that context too and the other side
is a lot of us were curious like
how would they be able to cut back and
forth in the sitcom world and in the
real world with sword and the way they
handled the sitcom world i loved how
there was this percolating
unease and tension throughout it it's
like this isn't the funniness that once
was
like it's kind of funny they also was as
it was another layer on top of it was
how like those 90s sitcoms often were
that's when they really weren't afraid
at times to kind of have some heavier
dramatic moments and deal with like
real world [ __ ] sometimes the
conversations that take that tone you're
like
it kind of reminded me of those kind of
shows back then you know like roseanne
would actually do that yeah
sure and that's the thing too is i feel
like the sitcom gag is almost a gift
that keeps on giving because it just
keeps contributing to this
uncanny valley that gets weirder and
weirder the more context they throw into
it
and yeah this episode i thought was
really expert in the way it matched
so many perspectives and aspects and
angles of the world together like even
just transitioning through monica's
brief moments of flashing through what
it was like being inside wanda's fantasy
before coming out and you know getting a
sword briefing and all that stuff
was really lucid i think i think it's
really impressive it's so obvious if
there's like these little
hints throughout that you just can't
help but start speculating on because
wanda says why aren't you doing
something to the kids like in
the beginning like why aren't you doing
what i want you to do yeah i love how
they use
a lot of the mystery questions and then
to distract you from that
they'll go to like the sitcom world
they're in
you know oh this is just a funny problem
yeah yeah why don't you kids listen to
me let me try to get you to be quiet uh
put some alcohol in there kids you can't
control them like twice in that scene
was she can't seem to get a hold of her
kids
she can seem to control everything or
she's losing control but then you go to
like
monica rambo's clothes and they see that
they converted her clothing into
the clothes that wanna created so
whatever she's creating there you step
outside of it it can become a reality
reality remixed so i'm like wondering is
did the kids have something to do
with maybe what this hayward guy really
wants in the end like i think there's
something
much more to tommy and billy than we
realize to
their development especially the fact
that wanda can't control them
yeah they they seem to really take like
make point that out we cannot control
them they age when they want to age
yeah having her try to talk them out
about aging this is so
strange this is one that she can't get a
hold of she if she
seems to control everything but this is
scary
scared talk about scary too the showdown
where she comes out and confronts
them see like the thing i really admired
about this episode especially and what i
think is very curious and clever about
the show overall is i think that
all the information they're trickling
out and all the things they have us
speculating over throughout the week
is very intentional by this episode
because they don't seem afraid
to confront a lot of things just head-on
like this episode confronted a bunch of
stuff i wasn't expecting to confront at
least yeah
until the next one or later like how
scarlet witch could have taken out
thanos
to say what all the nerds are saying
captain marvel could have
probably done it too but but noah's got
some some
some trouble there she's got some strain
yeah she's she had a reaction to that
moment
of some kind of like i don't want to
talk about this because the last time
you saw monica rambo which since she was
a little girl in captain marvel and it
was like
a superhero i look up to you and there's
obviously some estranged
tensions that happen between her and her
mom and i imagine it has something
to do with carol danvers as well yeah i
feel like there's something going back
there
but it just it was it would be a cameo
it wasn't just like
it was like this is a moment there's
like a hint of trauma or
pain behind it in some in some fashion
right and also when she goes out to talk
to the people the sword yeah what a
great scene
she goes let's talk to them she has her
accent she does she has her russian
accent i don't know
what that means i have no clue what that
means because
when she did not have her accent at all
in infinity war
i thought the writers are or maybe it
was the russo brothers who did come out
and
say something like well you know she's
been adapting to american culture so the
accent fades over
i thought they had some justification
for it but then the fact that her
accent it's clearly there yeah
it's clearly there she's going backwards
to i don't know what it means
yeah i'm like maybe it just comes out
when she's like just the most
clear expression of her id yeah yeah in
her subconscious i
i have no idea but still man that was a
good touch though
that was a great touch because it grips
you you know and it makes you
stop and go wait a minute is that her
original accent well it's like when you
first meet her in age of ultron they
even talk about that how like sh
she wasn't on the good side initially
and then eventually she joins the
avengers so it's kind of like going back
to her
villainous roots of when we first met
her in this in
in the mcu itself playing with our
perceptions man
well and again going back to hayward i
mean his whole thing is a bunch of
atrocities
and ah that's not the full context
though you know yeah
so i yeah untrustworthy guy and i think
a really eerie thing to confirm like the
a real
unsettling aspect of this is she's
creating this world that's all positive
and bubbly but underneath the surface of
it all they're all in pain
monica describes it as torture and
feeling violated norm
is miserable yeah he's miserable
underneath it and
that can't have been the first time
vision's done that because as we saw in
the last episode with the notes
it said that vision has done that before
to norm yeah it is like the the role
wolverine kind of was helping to serve
him but um yeah so that can't happen the
first time
yeah i mean although they played it like
it was the first time i
keep sitting here going is that
something they just edited kind of
funkily out of order or is this
something where yeah it's just been
edited out of this reality a few
different times or something
right we haven't seen it well guys this
was
a a hell of an episode and elizabeth
both
i mean it's so easy to get so caught up
in the world of the mcu marvel of where
the show is going kudos to the writers
the directing the editing the music and
absolutely positive i mean the guy plays
norm that was great
dude does that shift he was good it was
elizabeth olsen and paul bettany
wow they were incredible the kids are
good too
oh dude they crushed my heart yeah the
kids are good the kids are like hop
between horror movie villain
two oh your kids are really sweet are
you guys adorable or is this bright
burger
all right guys well leave your thoughts
down below what the hell do you think is
happening subscribe click the
notification bell hit that like button
last but not least
anissa oliva gotta shout you out my dear
uh
it's been such a busy past couple months
i felt like we
you know would be a lot easier to keep
in touch and talk regularly
a lot more and i'm sorry we haven't been
able to talk as much i do miss the hell
out of you
we got to have a proper conversation
full on conversation
in detail as soon as possible gas
station video just know that we're both
thinking about you
an awful lot right now i'm looking at
stuff that you've given us that are all
on the on the wall right here
you got like a wall of a knee a wall of
an issa over here
shrine anissa i'm incredibly grateful
for you
you'll forever be in my heart thank you
so much for being you and i promise we
will reconnect soon
don't go i'll wand on us no and force us
into a situation we don't want it hurts